and let's begin if you're jay gruden who
is widely expected to be the new
offensive coordinator of the jaguars
would you rather have gardner minshew or
a minshu nick foles quarterback
competition
definitely rather have minchu foals you
know nick foles after he hurt himself
last year in the first quarter of the
first game
just never got it going and i'm not
saying that nick foles is going to be a
top 15 quarterback and lead you to the
promised land i'm not necessarily saying
that
but there's a reason they gave him all
that money even though it might have
been misplaced
i want to see a fair off-season program
with him in it i want to see them go
head-to-head in the summer
and the way that foals has been and
obviously he got hurt and as as erratic
as minshew was
but as as fun
and occasionally as extremely effective
as he was what's the harm in having both
guys on your team
you know i've said in the past that the
jaguars would be better served by
picking one of the two guys specifically
minshu and finding a way out of the
falls contract the problem is there's
not gonna be an easy way out you're not
gonna trade him with so many veteran
free agents available this year look at
the list of names of guys who are out
there who's gonna trade for nick foles
when the jury's still out on whether or
not he can get it done anywhere except
in philadelphia and nick foles isn't
going to be the typical high-priced
quarterback who's got a chip on his
shoulder and a bug up his butt because
he's not playing if they decide that
gardner-minshew's the guy foles will be
supportive he'll be ready to go if
called upon to play and i i really do
think one of the reasons the owner of
the team shot khan gave doug marone the
coach and dave caldwell the gm another
year
is to see what they could do with
minshew they found minshew in round six
they've developed him let's see what
minshu can do so i think if there is a
competition it's going to be
weighted in favor of minshew and i think
foles is fine with that foles will be
ready to go he'll be a good teammate
he'll help teach minshu what he needs to
know and if minshu gets hurt foals will
be ready to play peter
bring them both back that's all i can
say mike it's the best way to hedge your
bet and it would be one thing if nick
foles
were a jerk and if he's thinking boy i'm
gonna be a problem
if uh if you guys pick menchu but he's
josh mccown i mean he's just he's a
great guy he's a total team guy and
whatever the decision is he's gonna live
with it and do what's best for the team
he's made his money far more than
anybody thought he would ever get paid
he's got his super bowl ring super bowl
mvp trophy and he's always been a great
teammate all right
if you're a dolphins fan would you
rather take your chances with tuatanga
viloa and number five or trade up and
give up the draft capital that they have
plenty of to get joe burrow at number
one
well i don't know that you're going to
be able to move up and get joe burrow if
you're the cincinnati bengals you know
mike brown has a long history of being
very stubborn about the draft
and uh the first year i ever covered the
nfl i covered the bengals and that was
in 1984 was the steve young year and you
know the bengals are pragmatic but
they're also very very stubborn
if they don't think they can sign a guy
they're gonna they're gonna try to get
what they can for him but i only say
that because now that jimmy burrow has
come out and said
joe will be happy to play for the
bengals be happy to play for whoever
why in the world would you trade the
opportunity
uh to get uh
you know to pick the guy you really want
and again mike we're not going to be
able to answer this question until
probably early april we're not going to
be able to know fully how tag veloa is
feeling physically how he's doing
i talked to a veteran nfl team doctor
last week and i said
two high ankle sprains and a major hip
injury in the span of 13 months
for this quarterback are you worried
about him being injury prone and he said
no these are all
active injuries there's nothing freak
here this is him getting hit this is him
getting hurt while being a physical
player so i'm not worried about that but
i have to believe
that some teams at the top of the draft
are going to be nervous about that
as dan orlowski told me last week he
said listen it's going to take a
courageous gm to pick tua it's going to
take a create courageous gm to pass on
tua
and after tua was injured in november i
canvassed more than
10 fewer than 20 general managers for
their thoughts on what it meant for tua
and and one pointed out very candidly
three lower body injuries at the college
level is a huge red flag because if
you're going to get injured there if
you're going to have durability issues
there it's only going to potentially get
worse at the next level when you're
getting hit harder by larger faster and
or stronger men so look it's it's uh
it's a tough call for the dolphins um
but you're right what would it take at
some point there's an offer you put on
the table that mike brown can't refuse
but how much does that take and is it
really worth giving up that much of your
future
on uh the difference between tua and joe
burrow it may not be worth it for what
the bengals would want in order to pass
on a guy who could maybe transform the
franchise and put people in the seats
something the bengals are having a hard
time doing all right if it can be only
one
would you rather see tom brady or drew
brees playing for a new team in 2020
peter
i'd rather see brady play for a new team
um i just have this feeling like
uh
you know it's not that it's played out
in new england because i definitely
think brady would go back but i think
the thought of brady playing somewhere
else
might be a little bit energizing to him
the thought of him going to vegas the
thought of him going to la and being the
new billboard for the chargers i think
that'd be really energizing to him
whereas
not to say that it wouldn't be the same
for drew brees
but
i just think the marriage between brees
and sean payton
uh i i just think right now for the
future knowing how badly the saints want
to play 2020 with brees
that i just think it's more natural to
think of brees back in new orleans than
i think it is to imagine brady back in
new england
yeah and and i i think that it's more
fascinating to see what tom brady can do
without bill belichick what bill
belichick can do without tom brady so
between the two i would rather see brady
with another team but you know we talked
about this last week if the saints pay
brees how in the world do you keep
taysom hill around and is the uh the
coach of the patriots bill belichick the
guy who shows up and makes taysom hill
an offer that the saints can't match and
gladly gives up a low first round pick
to make taysom hill his new tom brady
there's a lot of dominoes that are going
to fall it's going to be a crazy
offseason peter when you look at all of
the free agent quarterbacks who are out
there all the moving parts and we don't
know what the various teams are going to
want to do they're not going to tell us
until they do it bill belichick surely
loves one of these quarterbacks at least
one of them he's going to go after one
of them if he doesn't keep tom brady we
just won't know who it is until it
happens
mike
last week uh
a general manager in the nfl and i were
having a conversation
and he said what would you think
uh
what would you think it would take
to make the saints not match an offer on
taysom hill
and this is a team that has
a quarterback
and i said wow
how would mr x feel about you bringing
in taysom hill
and that is one of the first problems
but the end of the conversation he said
we're not going to be the only ones who
are going to have some serious internal
conversations about taysom hill if i'm
the saints
i'm worried about the taysom hill
conundrum and worried about some team
making an offer for him i don't know
that it'll happen because everybody out
there knows mike that taysom hill is
beloved by sean payton and i believe
that if i had to go to vegas right now
and put five bucks on the saints opening
day quarterback in 2021
i'd put five bucks on taysom hill
hey peter you know who i i i mean i
obviously i'm not going to try to out
your source but we're watching the
highlights of what taysom hill did
against the minnesota vikings in the
wild card round he was the best player
on the field that day for either team
hey and that we played a clip
in the aftermath of that game where paul
allen calling the play where drew brees
fumbles when danielle hunter comes at
him in the fourth quarter when the
saints could have taken the lead and
before the snap paul allen says i can't
believe i'm saying it's a relief to see
drew brees back in the game but it was
because taysom hill was unstoppable and
you look at what the vikings are dealing
with with kirk cousins one more year
you you come up with a deal with taysom
hill where the money really kicks in in
2021 uh with guarantees in 2021 uh after
after cousins would be off the books
interesting possibilities and i think
you have to take taysom hill seriously
especially if you're one of the teams
that's tried to chase him around and
stop him like the vikings had to do a
few weeks ago all right a couple more of
these before we break how about this if
you were the chiefs would you rather
have a compromised chris jones for 80
percent of your snaps on defense or a
full go chris jones only on third downs
i'd rather have him on every down he was
just too valuable in the championship
game and i think that's a little bit of
a faulty question because the kansas
city chiefs now have 13 days for chris
jones to get treatment for five hours a
day and you know he's not going to be
he's going to be
more
ready or ready or whatever the
the the term would be
he's going to be more prepared to play
in the super bowl than he was in this
championship game
i absolutely want him
i want him to play you know if there's
65 defensive snaps i want to play in 50
of those in the super bowl
oh absolutely and look it's not just
what he does on third down
because who cares about third down with
the san francisco 49ers they're gonna
run the ball on third down you want him
out there to help blow up those
sophisticated and exotic run schemes
that kyle shanahan has created uh and no
one can stop and if you can't if you
can't stop that running scheme and as i
said earlier we're gonna know within the
first quarter quarter and a half whether
or not the chiefs can stop it they're
not going to adjust during the game to
it they're going to be able to stop it
or they're not chris jones needs to be
out there for them to have a chance to
stop
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports